How's it sound if you break something I can fix it I?
I Have a school for young people, who are like you Ching we could be your new family
If you like
Go
Kurt where is she... where is she? i'm sorry
Jeaan!
She should be dead, whatever happened up there made her stronger. She's changing into's what?
I'm scared I'm gonna lose control
Bad things happen to people like
I'm not giving up on you Jean this is what family does ..stop..we take care of each other ..stopp!..
That Power destroyed everything that it ever came into contact with
Until you
What they don't understand they fear?
And what they fear we seek to destroy?
Are you scared little girl who answers to a man in a chair are you the most powerful creature on the planet
She'll kill us all
jeaan!
This is your fault Charles, tell me how we fix this charles tell me what to do... I don't know what to do
the girl dies
She's still Jean which is still helping
Sometimes we want to believe people are something that they are not
When the time you realize who they are
It's too late
She's coming
X-men Dark Phoenix
You